ON THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS
ABOUT S-HOLE COUNTRIES BUT
ONE SIMPLE QUESTION, CAN WE
REALLY TRUST ANYTHING SAID
EVEN THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
CALLED OUT DURBIN FOR
INVENTING A QUOTE DENYING
THE DEMOCRATS' CLAIM 2013
I CAN'T EVEN STAND TO LOOK
AT YOU, CLOSED QUOTE.
OBAMA'S PRESS SECRETARY AT
THE TIME JAY CARNEY
RESPONDING I LOOKED INTO
THIS AND SPOKE WITH SOMEBODY
WHO WAS IN THAT MEETING AND
IT DID NOT HAPPEN.
AND HERE'S A LOOK BACK AT
>> IF I READ THIS TO YOU AND
DIDN'T TELL YOU THAT IT WAS
AN FBI AGENT DESCRIBING WHAT
AMERICANS HAD DONE TO
PRISONERS IN THEIR CONTROL,
YOU WOULD MOST CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THIS MUST HAVE
HAPPENED BY NAZIS, SOVIETS
IN THEIR GO
IN THEIR GULAGS OR SOME MAD
MACHINE.
>> Laura: FOR REACTION,
LET'S BRING IN FORMER
GEORGIA, FORMER OBAMA
ROBIN BEERO ROBIN, LET'S
START WITH YOU ON THIS.
I REMEMBER IN 2005 THAT DICK
DURBIN COMMENT ABOUT OUR
TROOPS.
MY PRODUCER AT THE TIME LEE
HA BIB WAS WATCHING.
HE CALLED ME AND SAID DID
YOU HEAR WHAT DICK DURBIN
IMAGINE MAKING A STATEMENT
ABOUT THE U.S. MILITARY SUCH
AS THAT THAT ONE STATEMENT
TOLD ME ONE ABOUT DICK
DURBIN THAN ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU CAN POINT TO ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT TRUMP SAID
ABOUT CERTAIN COUNTRIES THAT
SEND A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER OF VISA LOTTERY
NUMBERS US.
YOUR REACTION?
>> I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
UP THAT STATEMENT I'M A ARMY
VETERAN RANGER.
I HAD THE ARMY OF SERVING.
I WAS VERY MUCH OFFENDED BY
THAT STATEMENT.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOW A
POLITICIAN IS HE ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE SAYING THINGS.
AND OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
SEND THEIR PEOPLE HERE
FLEEING PARADISE VACATION
THERE?
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S COMMENTS FROM
YESTERDAY?
>> Laura: I'M SORRY, YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT DURBIN.
WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THOSE
COUNTRIES?
THE RECKLESS FLZ THAT HE
USES WHEN HE SAYS THESE
THINGS.
THAT STATEMENT, HOWEVER YOU
CUT IT, CAME OUT AS OVERTLY
RACIST TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Laura: OVERTLY?
HOW IS IT RACIST TO SAY.
>> IT CAME OUT THAT WAY.
>> Laura: IT CAME OUT THAT
WAY BECAUSE THE MEDIA WANTS
TO FULFILL -- JASON, THEY
HAVE BEEN PLAYING THE RACE
CARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I SUBMIT THEY ARE OUT OF
IDEAS.
YOUR REACTION?
>> NO, I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
PARDON MY VOICE HERE.
I'M FIGHTING A LITTLE SORE
THROAT.
NO, IT'S THE ONLY THING THEY
HAVE.
LOOK, THERE WERE SIX MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS IN THAT ROOM.
THERE'S ONLY ONE DEMOCRAT.
AND ONLY THE DEMOCRAT IS
SAYING THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED.
AND I THINK IT'S HIGHLY
SUSPECT WHEN DICK DURBIN WHO
HAS A HISTORY OF DOING.
AND I THINK IT WAS A GERMAN
TO ME I'M UPSET THAT I CAN'T
TRUST YOU AGAIN.
THAT'S THE REPUTATION THAT
DICK DURBIN HAS EARNED IN
THIS SITUATION.
AND IT IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
WRONG WHAT IS HE SAYING WHEN
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING NO,
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.